okay and it's your birthday and for your
birthday he gets you let's say a 500
gift
okay and you're you're happy right it's
very it's thoughtful it's specific to
you then you found out last year
he got his ex-girlfriend an entire
birthday party
how does that make you feel he he she he
went to he did the most he he rented out
the nicest hotel in London he got her
everything she wanted the year before
we're different people too it's a
different relationship and maybe like
you know he he bought her flowers every
day 365 days a year and he didn't do
that for me it's like well if that's
what makes her happy he's gonna do it
makes her happy exactly I mean I get I
get the angle what you're saying is like
oh he she did you know he did all that
for her why am I not good enough but the
second you compare yourself you lose
yeah yeah and I I agree but I'm just
saying that's how men look at like your
past is like basically like you've given
it for free okay so here's my question
to that because all right I love like
everything we're talking about okay so
to all the viewers out there including
myself right
you live life there's gray area you live
and you [ __ ] learn right
so where the [ __ ] do we go from here so
do I play the shame game where everybody
walks away a [ __ ] loser because I can
do that I beat myself up my entire life
for every decision I've ever made right
it got me nowhere no so I I value myself
I see the world differently through a
series of events right
so what the [ __ ] comes next because
that's where I'm confused right because
I'm not it's like I did if you don't if
it's not like gifted to you like even in
your situation like your dad provided
you a life that like so many people
would kill for like you know what I mean
so that's why it's like
it's sucks because the reason I hate
these conversations is because it's
never about like empathy do I understand
the the the scales and how someone may
view for this this that and the third
okay but moving forward then what so
okay so I'm I'm just gonna like I said
make it about myself I'm 30 single mom
my [ __ ] checkered passes all over
Instagram you know what I mean I have
people like you or she's a hoe she's a
she's literally known for this okay
so what would what would be your advice
to people like me then but I don't
believe in gray area I believe black and
white okay that's unfortunate because
there's gray anymore
I mean I just think there's consequences
for your decisions and I just think like
that my best advice would be to like
lower your standards
like that because because I just think
there's going to be consequences for
putting you know promiscuous stuff on
the internet okay and you probably won't
get the type of guy that you could have
got at 22. do you know why it wasn't
meant to be then do you know what I'll
tell you I would say because I'm 30 and
I'm single out of a situation that
actually is not because I was a hoe and
I was doing whatever whatever people
can't call me that I made it my decision
to be with somebody that hurt me a lot
and I stayed for five years I came out
super late and you know what I realized
what my what what I learned is that I
know now that I have to be selective and
I have to think if me taking longer to
get to that stage Is What It Takes then
that's what it takes you accept your
future you accept everything with
gratitude because as long as you're
breathing that's the most important
thing at least you've got your child I
am not afraid because I know the quality
of women that I am I know my value
regardless of whether I'm 30 40 50. do
you understand so you don't be afraid by
other people's time limits and
limitations and all of these things
because it actually doesn't matter and
I'll tell you why now that your value
goes down
like no but I'm saying
I'll tell you why because since Mr
Andrew take to explain something about
status I understand very well what that
actually means and as a woman the
quality and the value that I hold for
myself is actually the kind of value and
quality that a man will appreciate the
status you'll bring to him whether or
not I'm a virgin because I've worked on
myself to be a woman of quality and
substance I respect myself and I handle
myself as such okay and that is the way
that you're going to actually overcome
all of these bad mistakes that you've
made because who you are right now
actually will make a difference if you
stick to it and if you mean it and if
you've always been that way there's
always another another story for
everybody it doesn't matter you'll be a
fan that's more emotionally mature you
know I would say to you what are you
about to say Andrew because you just
started speaking I want to say um
I want to hear I really because because
you've been through a lot in your life I
like when I when she told me that you
were going to be on and we were going to
be on this panel together I started
watching a bunch of your videos and it
really was like there's so much that you
have been through which is why you have
a well of of wisdom right and the
difference between me and you is that
you're glorified for it and I am burned
at the stake for everything that I've
been through and I it's so funny because
people have always said that we were two
sides of the same coin as far as like
well if Andrew tank gets bambering your
energy get banned because there's we are
all about accountability and [ __ ]
truth right yeah okay so you've been
through a lot I've been through a lot
I'm seen as used Goods you're seen as a
high value man so if you're me then then
what what's next yeah it's really
interesting and it's interesting you
make the observation and you are correct
that's the difference between the
masculine and The Feminine it's kind of
it's unfair I guess the world's not fair
but that's the difference in Damascus
and The Feminine men are respected for
going through things and surviving and
women are the complete opposite they're
shame for going through things and
surviving if you look at women love
scars on men for a reason he's gone
through something here they're War
wounds yeah men don't want a chick
covered in scars I'll say this right now
that a woman the more trauma she goes
through the more masculine she naturally
becomes and if you were to give me my
ideal woman I would not want of of
wanting her to have a hard life and a
bunch of trauma I like the idea of her
having a soft feminine life and being a
soft person and I can take care of her
and protect her whereas as a man to be a
good man you need to have been through a
bunch of trauma because if you haven't
been through trauma as a man you're a
weakling you have to have been through a
bunch of [ __ ] so the masculine the
feminine is a very interesting point
there as for
I don't know I don't know your history I
don't know the past but we can just talk
in general generalizations in regards
people like me I guess under the same
umbrella I don't know any of it but
we'll give generalizations one of the
main reasons that men are scared of a
female with history is is because it
makes the man insecure and and scared
dogs bite so this is why men will snap
or get angry quick or they'll bring up
your his if you if you get an argument
with him he'll bring up your history
that uh whatever but a law of it is
insecurity and it's not insecurity
because the man is insecure the woman
the women the female Paradigm in society
convinces men any man who says anything
you're insecure it's not insecure in
that way it's insecure in a very
realistic logical way like I was saying
earlier she's had a lot of life
experience let's be honest am I the
richest guy she's ever had no am I the
most famous guy she's ever had no am I
the best looking guy she's ever had no
like what's keeping her here and then
part of it comes down to well at my
second place could if she could do
better would she do better like there's
a whole bunch of insecurity involved and
that's where tiny things like I'm
talking I know it sounds like dumb [ __ ]
tiny things about the favorite car brand
become more important than ever right
it's it's your job as a woman regardless
of how much sexual history you've had or
what guy you're with Etc it's your job
as a woman to make your man feel secure
in the fact and make him feel like a man
like Auntie was saying make him feel
like the man no matter what he does so
that he feels like you really truly
believe he's the best choice for you on
the planet that's your job to do now if
you've had a checkered past that's
perhaps more difficult you need to be
more tactful with it more tactical about
it but you have to achieve the same
result you have to do the exact same
thing right so yeah it's easy for me if
I get a a 21 year old virgin from some
Village in Slovakia and I'm
multi-millionaire Andrew Tate of course
it's a very easy she's never had better
she'll never get better she's never been
anywhere boom boom easy one right but
like you said the world's not so so so
idealistic the reality is that people
have had relationships etc etc but a man
is happiest in the relationship when he
feels like man in the house and when he
truly feels like you believe he's the
best man that you could possibly ever
get and have ever gotten because a man
is jealous I'll tell you something
I used to say this to girls it's like a
joke
I just said no but I say it's a joke so
you cheated on me before I met you
and she'd be like what do you mean I
didn't even know he was like yeah you
[ __ ] that guy before I even knew you
beat on me and they used to laugh
whatever but that's how men think that's
the male mind like I love you and you've
been [ __ ] by who but I didn't know you
I don't care if you knew me you
shouldn't weigh it dude that's the male
mind so he is it competition with all of
your exes and all of your lifestyle and
all the things you've done permanently
and it's down to you as a woman to sit
there and go how do I make him secure in
himself and secure in his masculinity
and make him believe that investing in
me is still worthwhile because I still
truly value him despite the fact that I
could do XYZ I hope that gives some
clarity but that's that's the answer you
know what I would have said I would have
said oh for anybody in that situation
come off social media and just Raise
Your Child So the person who meets
you've got nothing to but I never knew
you I never knew you were because I
don't I've never heard of you before so
when I spoke to you
by the way people by the way you're
saying like what's on us on the internet
let me say you're a nicer person than
what you sound like like what you
perceive to be like you were saying oh
the pills go there she's a horse she's a
[ __ ] and I've heard I've heard the name
but I don't know anything about you and
I was saying that if you didn't have
nothing on social media about your
checkered past and you met somebody the
same way how I met you and I Converse
and I got to know you it's the same way
that they would
yeah and and it is interesting and it's
also back to Damascus and feminine right
because I'm all over the Internet and
supposedly I'm misogynist and I'm evil
and all this crap right but if I meet of
a girl even if she disagrees with me in
fact I'll say this I've never ever met a
single female who's ever come out to me
and disagree with me every woman comes
up to me and loves what I says but let's
imagine I met this imaginary girl she
was sitting me and if I were to have a
10 minute conversation with her by the
time I explained the level to which they
tried to destroy me how they tried to
freeze all my bank accounts raise
illegal charges against me put me in
jail for things I didn't do put a travel
ban take my passport all this garbage by
the time I explain how hard they tried
to hurt me and failed she'll want me
because she'll be like you can't kill
this guy
like you say a bunch of [ __ ] I don't
like but you know what you're you're the
man so it is about experience and it is
different and that's a really good point
about social media social media
amplifies all of this [ __ ] it amplifies
all these problems everything we're
discussing everything we've discussed
back to the beginning from status to
promiscuity to your past it's all social
media without social video a lot of it
goes away and I think that's why me and
my men love so long is that he doesn't
do social media and there's nothing on
there about me I feel like to answer
your question too because I have had
people
say that as a solution and it's like you
can run but you cannot hide from the
truth and I have shared why my voice has
been so impactful and will continue to
be impactful is because I have put
myself out there and I have been
punished for being honest so it's like I
have been giving a platform given a
platform and a voice for a reason even
sitting down in this conversation
thinking there's not one person I'm
probably gonna agree with and probably
going to want to leave
um I have been called here for a reason
so it's like I can't go against what is
in my heart and what I am coded to be
and that's why I feel like it's
important for me to sit here and
represent people who feel like me
because it's like I didn't I don't want
to say I didn't I don't want to say that
um I just feel like I don't see a lot of
women Under My Umbrella who feel the way
that I feel I don't see opinion shared
that I that would be worded the way that
I feel nothing I feel like a lot of my
thoughts are very unique and it's it's
kind of scary because I have been
through different things I I see the
world in a different place and when I
even even speak online people think I'm
[ __ ] speaking Swahili yeah so it's
like and I know no and I know exactly
what you're saying and you're making
good points and it's just I think that
regardless of whether like we're talking
about different positions I compare
everything to chess I know it's annoying
we're looking at different positions on
the chess board but the rules are still
the same right okay no matter how bad
your position is or how good your
position is you're still trying to
achieve the same objectives and and you
want you want the man to get high status
and you want the man to feel secure in
himself and I think it's it's very
difficult I can only talk from the male
perspective because I am a man it is
very difficult if I are to meet a woman
who I liked very much but she had X
whatever pass whatever my concerns would
be how do I know that I'm still the
number one how do I know I'm most
important in her life especially if I
don't measure up in certain key metrics
and two the second thing that's most
scary for men is we understand that men
are constantly after what we have like
your inboxes are all full like they may
not be with guys you want to reply to
but guys are still trying to get it
that's the male life the male life is
people are trying to take everything
from me and and that's very scary and
you have to make your man really believe
like that's impossible if a man truly
believes that nobody can take you from
him he's going to love you in a
different way it you can give me you can
give me two carbon copies of the same
chick but one I think might cheat in the
right circumstances and one I know no
matter what would never leave me the
love I'll feel for this one is a
different planet to the love I feel for
this one even though the same person
right because that's every man's biggest
fear is a woman cheating or leaving
because there's something visceral and
something different about it I know I
talk things and I say men can do things
and women can't and all this stuff but
like if a woman cheats on a man that
hurts the man on a level that it doesn't
hurt the woman if the man shoots on her
it's different it's it's different
biologically it's different it's
different evolutionarily like that's
what men used to fight and die over you
talk to my chick you look at my eyes
yeah it's like you masculinize him on
every level like and this is why you see
these tick tocks right you see these
tick tocks me and my man went on a break
got back together he [ __ ] 20 girl and
now he's crying because I went on a date
yes completely yes because the the
level is different it's just a different
thing so you have to understand the
paradigms you have to understand to play
the game and that's how you make men
happy and I know very well how I like to
believe that I know I would know very
well how to make a woman happy and and I
know and whether I do that or not is a
conscious decision and that's where you
get to a certain level of grand Mastery
where I if I get a woman I will
literally decide out of 10 how happy do
I want her do I want does she deserve to
be happy 10 or should I keep her like
crying half the time that it's very
conscious and women don't think that way
but I'm saying if you're a smart if
you're a cutting woman you can be like
that you could be a bit more like you
know what I want him infatuated with me
this guy ain't worth the time that guy I
want and then when you're gonna do that
just like the game of chess if you play
chess it's not big moves that make you
lose it's small positional plays it's
that time you argued about your favorite
car it's a time you disagree with him
about the favorite band it's the dumb
[ __ ] that adds up whereas really
truthfully if you're truly smart about
the game you can get him to a point
after a few months where he's like she's
my soul
she loves everything I love we think the
same our hearts are connected boom and
then you're safe just don't [ __ ] it up
from there but I just feel like it's so
contradicting to I feel like what your
overall message is which is about truth
so it's like if if my truth like if it
can be destroyed by the truth it should
be destroyed by the truth so that's what
I'm trying to figure out like why it's
it's really mind-boggling to me because
I feel like how could you even be
mentally emotionally sexually stimulated
by a woman who is just agreeable and you
know it just it doesn't have her own
mind I just don't see that that is
exactly that is exactly that is exactly
what every man wants we don't want you
to be complete robots we're not saying
we can't have a joke with you we can't
say we can't have a laugh with you we're
not saying can't have a personality but
when it comes to things like agreement
there is not a single man in the world
who's gonna say she's too agreeable she
just agrees with me on it she agrees me
on all the important things in my life
she's too agreeable I want someone else
[ __ ] no you're completely not be wrong
on that point it's a huge point this
idea that I understand if you're a
complete doormat and you set no
standards men might walk all over you
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
about agreeability and agreeableness as
a whole men love the idea of a agreeable
woman because it gives status and it
makes the man feel like he's a teacher
and makes the man feel in charge and it
satisfies his ego and to you they may be
small little tiny points but to him
they're a big deal if I were to sit I'm
telling you right now if I were to sit
with with one of my chicks or whatever
on my chick and I'll just sit in the
lambo and say lambo's the best car of
all of them I prefer to label she goes I
don't like that one I'm like listen I
bought them all and I [ __ ] said this
the best one shut up it would annoy me
because that's my reality I want her to
become part of my reality it's the thing
and you talk about truth it's
interesting because the truth of your
heart and the truth of your soul is to
be happy that's truth truth is for you
to end up happy now if you have to sit
there and agree on especially on a
subject you don't give a [ __ ] about
right if it's something you care about
and you are very knowledgeable about if
it's ancient Roman history and you have
a degree in
then fine argue the point but if it's
cars or something you don't even give a
[ __ ] about what yeah you're missing the
chance to get points on the scoreboard
easy free throw and you're just [ __ ]
it up going oh no no why why the truth
is just just play the game and win
you're gonna be the best female dating
I'll just learn a couple of words like
how many talks horsepower just throw
some words in like how much horsepower
is it that's it okay with all due
respect Not all men are like that some
men respect a woman that has their own
mind I know you and the type of men that
you're speaking on behalf of let me tell
you something like a woman that I
understand I agreeable to everything he
says like I've dated men that just
respect that I can make decisions that
will actually submissive women have
their own mind yeah completely there's
sometimes that he might be discussing
stuff that he might want to be discussed
and then sometimes we're like shut the
[ __ ] up and let me say what I got to say
yes and maybe I don't even believe in
star signs but my man's Sagittarius so
completely and submissive women have
their own mind because there's something
else you have to take into consideration
and this is super important and super
true the reason a lot of women don't
truly understand a lot of things about
relationships and and how it works with
men Etc it's because men will lie to you
men lie for the same reason you wear
makeup because men fall in love with
what they see men fall in love with what
they see and women fall in love with
what they hear so we will lie to you so
you'll go on a date with a guy and
you'll sit there and say I don't listen
no I'm I'm independent and what's that
man gonna say oh I love that that's
exactly the kind of woman I want come
suck this it's a [ __ ] lie that is not
what he wants there it's not what he
wants I'm telling you this one for now
yeah he'll he can't be bothered to argue
with you at dinner because he doesn't
because and you know what most men
aren't smooth enough to do it I can sit
with a chick and disagree with her and
be funny enough and smart enough and
charismatic enough and I'm high status
and enough and she respects me enough to
listen but if I'm just some normal dude
and I start arguing with a chick she's
going to bounce on the dinner and say
[ __ ] you yeah good to see y'all so most
dudes dating strategy most dudes mating
strategy is just pure agreement yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anything to get the puss because they're
[ __ ] dorks that's fine that that
that's the truth right a real G will sit
there and say what do you mean I don't
want to hear this [ __ ] I'm telling you
the Baseline of how men truly function
if I'm expected to fight and die to
protect you because that's what is
expected of Me by society and of you you
may think you don't expect that of me
but if we're walking down through London
the middle of the night and two guys
come up with machets you're gonna hide
behind me knowing I'm gonna die because
I can't win this fight I'm expected to
die to protect you well then I expect
you to agree with me I'm not here to
[ __ ] die for somebody who disagrees
with me on everything that's not what
I'm here to [ __ ] if I have that
obligation to die on the spot for you
you have the obligation to pretend you
like BMWs so do your [ __ ] part and
shut up and yeah I'm not
the only difference between him and my
man and the level of respect is money
that's that's the only difference and
this is the same way he talks the same
way he is but people say like oh mama
anion's 40 000 so he can't talk to me
away Andrew Jake talks to his why not
completely and that's a big factor
though
you can't have a woman on bills she's
doing everything for herself I mean
she's a man and then you're gonna tell
her of course but I'm sorry to do this
but you you're different you never need
to work you take all that stress away
from me then she'll be a lot worse
why does money have to matter for
submissions
enough money to make sure that she
doesn't need to work go and deal with
her boss every day I don't know all the
stress all these bills then of course
she's going to look up to you and be
like but okay he pays my bills only
about 40 000. so I just just never I
grew up in a one percent family I never
expected a dude to pay for everything I
don't know
but and I still think
my friends both of my clients worked but
my mom still submitted to my dad like it
wasn't the guy the point is is in every
relationship that's beautiful every
relationship that's Happy regardless of
the social economic scale regardless of
how rich or poor they are regardless of
how famous they are regardless of how
whatever and every relationship where
people are truly happy pay attention the
man is in charge
he's the top G of that house his woman
makes him feel that way she respects him
for what he does and they are happy
we're talking about me out here in the
world social media whatever it doesn't
matter every man wants to be the man of
his household the king of his castle
every single happy relationship is the
same I genuinely implore you to name a
happy relationship with a woman's in
charge name one you can't they end up
broken up the [ __ ] she leaves him
whatever the name a happy relationship
where the woman doesn't blindly say okay
I won't go to that concert name one
there is only one framework in which
people are happy with the man in charge
the woman trusts and respects him enough
to let him be in charge and they're a
happy couple in relationship any other
type of relationship is a time bomb to
the end so if you want a happier
relationship that's what you should be
aiming for you need to be thinking you
need to be perspicacious enough and
think about these things and sit and go
well that's the only way relationships
work so I need to build it that way I
think instead of coming along a Believer
you're going to reinvent the wheel okay
[Music]
I want to hit one more topic because
we're running out of time so so I want
to actually give
the ladies a chance to say what do you
guys disagree with
um from as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible